what's happening samuel leads here
i'm super good you booked a call you're
looking to do a joint venture
i just thought i'd give you a quick buzz
to see i might be able to
to go help property it's a bicep
property victorian house
here in southwest london and um it's a
motivated seller
uh he wants to retire move our tennessee
into a big house
properties on the market for just under
1.5
he's squeezing between 1.35 and 1.375
so you know slightly below market value
sort of selling price of
in the house is just under
i was going 1.5 ask that because i was
going to ask that because asking price
and market value are obviously two very
different things sometimes but
you've checked the actual market value
and you think 1.5 is reasonable
around 1.5 is essentially the right
sort of value for the property excellent
based on comparables
these flats would be around that sort of
price point so the
[Music]
in terms of the deal i know your main
question was about
how to find a joint venture which we'll
go on to but in terms of the deal
itself how confident either it would get
planning for flats
have there been flats in the street or
around the area have been houses that
have been converted into flats would it
be fitting with the area
yes so within a half mile radius
okay and also the cost to turn it into
flats did you say you're going out with
your builders soon or do you already
have an idea how much that would cost um
okay in terms of getting a joint venture
on it um
where are you at and what do you need
from me i need a partner because
we are getting hmo done to our family
home
and you know obviously i can't afford
that but it's very difficult
for me to find someone with deep enough
pockets
like that that's where i was i needed a
bit of guidance how do i do this
in a part in a city like london
do you live close to the property
brilliant well i mean the deal sounds
like a decent deal for what you've said
um i mean it's not like jumping up and
down isn't it amazing but it sounds like
a very solid reasonable deal
um there are investors that like to
invest in that kind of thing
so is it possible for you to get a joint
venture on this property i would say yes
i'd say is possible
as much as investing in the deal people
are also investing in you
so yeah um what's your kind of have you
got a track record of doing deals
or are you quite new to this industry
um so basically november is when we
decided to
convert our family home into a journal
yeah
i mean it's not going to be easy to get
someone to put in
half of i mean sorry all of the money
for a big deal
i mean how active are you on the you
know when we do like the wednesday
the wednesday calls and stuff are you
active on there
yeah i've been there every wednesday
okay cool
brilliant because i mean there's people
as you probably can see there's there
are people on that call that do have
money
so i mean i would definitely suggest on
wednesday
getting my attention and just being like
hey just to sort of celebrate i just
want to say i've got this deal this is
what it is
i do i am looking for a joint venture
partner um you know and to just kind of
put it out there in a non-salesy way i
definitely think that would be a smart
thing to do it might be that if you
can't get a joint venture for it it
might be that you can just pass the deal
on to somebody
and and and sell the deal but then get
like a project management fee or
something so you're being involved in
the deal you're getting paid to
have the deal but and you're getting
experience on it
you're building your track record on it
but it's an easier
sell than trying to get someone to put
in all the money
for just a percentage just sort of
saying to someone look you can have the
deal
you know i want two thousand pound up
front i want two thousand pound on
completion
and then i'm gonna charge ten percent of
the co of the conversion costs to
oversee the works because i live 10
minutes away
and then that way you're getting paid
you're getting a track record you build
an experience
i mean that might be worth doing as a
fallback option if you can't find
a full joint venture for it another
thing is as well and this is probably
stating the obvious
but rather than thinking just down the
lines of
you know our who what investors do i
know i mean it might be worth
thinking about who you might know on a
personal level like family and friends
and stuff
who might have some money or some equity
it might worth just thinking about that
because sometimes
for your first joint venture it can be
the person right under your nose is that
actually the person that ends up doing
the deal so
i mean those are a few pointers um i
wish i could wave a magic wand and just
appear you a joint venture partner but i
mean you know you've done the training
and you you're looking at the deal the
deal is looking good you've got full
support with me and steve and dave and
the team to help you
you know do due diligence on the deal um
you've got the platform to be able to
shout out to hundreds of investors
um you know so i mean those are just
some general thoughts because even if
this deal falls through
you probably want to learn from this
that you want joint venture partners in
the pipeline
even if you don't have a deal so don't
wait to find
a perfect deal before you start looking
for a jv partner if you're part
if you're part of the deal and stuff i
mean of course if you if you're selling
deals and stuff generally speaking you
should you should really be compliant
being compliant is more about protecting
you and protecting the investor rather
than it's illegal to do it
um so i'd probably just cross that
bridge i'd probably just say look
try and join venture on it if you can't
try and find someone that will buy off
you and do the project management side
of things and just cross that bridge
um you know but but i think yeah let's
see how we get on with the buildings
quote today and give me a shout on
wednesday evening
and then let's take it from there
know coming in just won't be well it
will be
enough to cover the mortgage but there
won't be anything
and we won't get them all because i
think yeah
with um well you know
it's nice you you need to have an exit
strategy in place
if you can't refinance it feasibly and
selling it's the only option
um you know what again i wouldn't even
think about it too much right now
i would just think about i just think
about getting a joint venture partner
getting a builder's quote on the
particular deal and
i would think about finding someone to
potentially sell it to
shout getting yourself known on
wednesday night i just worry about those
things right now
okay sure that you know would you like
to make more money out of it by
maybe sharing the profit yeah
you can do that you can absolutely can
do that joint venture with the owner
and another thing as well as this one
final piece of advice and then i
i do need to show but final piece of
advice is this you want to fill your
pipeline
with properties don't just be thinking
all about this property
you want to fill your pipeline with
other properties but i hope it goes well
all the best with the viewing today
thank you so much you're so welcome
cheerio now